MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So hi, welcome.
My name's Melody
Meckfessel, and I'm
an Engineering
Director at Google.
I'm responsible for
the developer tooling
and infrastructure for our
Cloud Platform and for Google
engineers.
TOMAS ISDAL: My
name is Tomas Isdal.
I'm a Software
Engineer, and I am
the Tech Lead for Managed VMs.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So we're really
excited to be here today
to talk to you about DevOps
at the speed of Google.
Google builds some of the
world's largest applications
and services, google.com,
Gmail, YouTube.
And the reason
our developers are
able to work efficiently to
build and run these services
is because we have a
great set of tools.
We've spent the last 15
years building and developing
these tools, and
we're so happy to be
able to offer them to you.
Today we're going to talk
through what Google offers
you, developers,
for getting code
out the door to your users.
But what do we mean by DevOps?
You all probably have a
somewhat different definition.
DevOps is a way of bringing
software developers
and operations together.
And I think the key
here is integration.
Learning and improving
your code by bringing dev--
writing your code--
and ops-- running
your service and your code--
in the Cloud closer together.
Automate away the parts of ops
you don't need to worry about.
The goal should be faster
development, faster deployment,
and ultimately, more
predictable operations.
So I've worked on a
bunch of projects--
experimental projects, as well
as massive legacy systems.
Some with small
communities and others
with hundreds of
millions of users.
And it can be so energizing
and invigorating to work
on these apps.
But it can also be
frustrating and exhausting.
We want to build
cool features, but we
end up spending a huge
amount of overhead, time,
overhead, on release
and deployment
or on operational work just
to keep things running.
And, just to tell
a story here, but I
remember sleeping with my pager
in my hand under my pillow,
for months at a time.
And I still have
nightmares of waking up
in the middle of the night,
with that buzzing in my hand,
of some failure I needed to fix.
So at Google, we think the cloud
is about much more than just
giving you raw VMs and storage.
We can offer you
much more than that.
You deserve to have a platform
that can automate away
the time consuming tasks that
you don't need to worry about,
to just get rid of
repetitive DevOps tasks,
so that we free up your time
to work on new features, apps,
or new business ideas.
So today we're going
to show you some
of the first steps
that we're taking
and the direction we're heading.
We're going to focus and
start when you already
have a working app.
And we're going to show
you how to track down
performance issues
with your app.
Test it, deploy it, how
you make sure that it
stays running smoothly.
TOMAS ISDAL: So we announced
Managed Virtual Machines
at the Google Live event
in March this year.
With Managed VMs, we
combine the flexibility
of Google Compute Engine, our
infrastructure as a service
offering, with the ease
of use and reliability
of App Engine, our platform
as a service offering.
If you're an existing App
Engine customer today,
you only need to change one
line in a configuration file
to take advantage of everything
Managed VMs has to offer.
For this session, we'll
use Managed VMs to power
all our demos.
When you run your
app on Managed VMs,
we set everything
up automatically,
so you get access to version
deployments, software updates,
automatic health checking.
If a VM goes bad,
we try to heal it,
by basically kicking
it and restarting it.
We do load balancing,
scaling, logging analysis.
We hook up debugging tools.
We do performance
tracking and so on.
Can we switch to a demo, please?
And well, best of all of
course, let's not forget this.
Google has a really good Site
Reliability Team spread out all
over the world.
So whenever there's a
power outage, network cut,
hurricanes, or anything else
impacting the data center where
you're app is serving,
you can trust us
that someone from
Google is awake.
And he is on track
to fix it already,
which means that we carry the
pagers, and you don't have to.
Can we switch to a demo?
So having confidence that your
app is running is just a start.
Another key part of
DevOps is understanding
how your app is performing.
So a benefit of Managed
VMs is that we hook up
the infrastructure you need
to answer questions like,
how is the performance
of my app right now?
So here, I have loaded
the WalkShare demo app.
You might have recognized
this from the previous session
and from the keynote.
So we got a bug report
that says that as you
load a lot of comments, this app
is starting to get really slow.
So I'm going to jump
in to Debug View
right here that we implemented
that can reproduce this issue.
So to jump in to really
reproduce the problem,
we heard that whenever there's
more than 5,000 comments,
things get really slow.
So I'm going to load
here, and then we're
going to see if we can
reproduce it here live as well.
There it loaded, but
I control the account,
like five, one, two, three.
So at least a three
second latency just
to load the next 50
comments in our app.
So this is obviously
not what we want
as we launch this
app to customers.
So a new feature in Cloud
that we've been working on
for some time is Cloud Tracing.
This allows you
to go in and look
to see which RPCs
your app is making.
Let's load up the Cloud
Trace UI here, and dive in,
to see what's going on.
So here's the list in the new
Cloud Console that shows us
the RPCs that are
made by this app.
So you see here, we
just had the request
to the comment-admin
page running
fetching comment
5,100 and forward.
As we dig in here, we see here
that they have higher response
to 2.3 seconds, so really slow.
We spend some time in
Datastore and RunQuery,
but we also spend
a lot of time just
fetching additional
Datastore results.
So my suspicion here is that
instead of fetching just the 50
comments that we care about, we
actually fetch 5,000 comments,
and then we fetch the 50
comments we care about.
Clearly not good.
So I'm going to load
our Source Code Viewer.
This viewer is hooked
up to the Git Repository
that's serving your app.
So this is basically
allowing me to browse
the PROD code we have right now.
Well, I see here, TODO, Isdal.
Do not use offset, it is slow!
So this means that when
I did an Offset Query,
if I had read the
documentation, I
would have known that it's
actually fetching everything
up to the offset
I'm looking for.
Also in the
documentation it says
that Query Cursors
is the way to go.
So I'm going to just
delete this one.
Delete the code here.
And I'm going to switch to
this conveniently placed cursor
implementation right below.
And then commit it.
So switch from offset to query.
As I hit commit
here, we have hooks
that notifies our build,
test, and deploy pipeline
that a change was made.
And this is going
to trigger first
a compilation of
all our source code.
This is Java, so we
need to compile it.
Then it's going to trigger
all our unit tests,
and if everything is
green, it will push it
to our staging environment.
So let's see how it's doing.
As we load this page, we
see that the deployment
is in progress, but our PROD app
is still using the old version.
So we don't have to worry
about pushing things
to PROD by accident.
So can we switch back
to the slides, please?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So pretty cool stuff.
We're going to talk a little
bit about continuous delivery
in a second, but I wanted
to share some numbers
behind the scale of Google's
internal developer tooling
and infrastructure.
So each and every
day, Google engineers
will execute 800,000
builds, generating over
two petabytes of build output.
Over 100 million test cases run
with over 30,000 changelists
each and every day.
Now, those numbers
may seem large,
but that's the type
of scale that we
want to deliver to you as part
of your DevOps experience.
So let's talk a little
bit about the importance
of continuous delivery.
So understanding application
performance, it's important,
but it's just one part of
the development life cycle.
The life cycle starts
an idea, a feature.
And then that turns into code.
It gets tested, and
then finally shipped.
And reliability of
delivery is important.
You want to know for sure that
the changes you're pushing
are not going to
break production.
You don't want to
just push and hope,
just pray that everything's
going to be OK.
And you certainly don't
want to be waking up
in the middle of the night
with that pager alert.
So getting to live
faster makes you happy.
It enables us to
innovate faster.
Whether you're working on a
feature or fixing a simple bug,
you want to see that
change live in minutes.
Not hours or days.
And this allows you to update
your application incrementally.
With faster deployment, you
have more frequent, and smaller
releases.
So you're updating your
application incrementally.
So that you know if something
goes wrong, it's easier for you
to trace back to the issue
and potentially roll back.
So I know nobody likes it
when changes take forever
to get to production,
but I think
what's even worse is not
knowing where your changes are.
So deployments, we
believe they should
be visible and predictable.
You shouldn't have to
have a crystal ball,
or have to chase down a
release manager or someone else
on your team, to know
which bits are where.
So from that get commit
that we made earlier,
we triggered the
Push-to-Deploy Pipeline.
As soon as we detect
that new commit,
we triggered a Jenkins-based
job to build, test, and deploy
the application.
So Jenkins is an
open source framework
that provides a very easy to use
continuous integration system.
It enables developers
to update their projects
and attain a fresh build.
And that's what we're
using behind the scenes
for the Push-to-Deploy workflow.
So these changes
should already be
deployed in our
staging environment.
But now we want to
promote those changes
from staging into
production so that our end
users can benefit from this.
And this really highlights
the idea of DevOps.
We're writing code, we
see there's an issue,
we track it down using Tracing.
We make the fix.
We commit it again.
We verify that it's in staging.
And then we're ready to
move it on to production.
So let's take a look at
our Release Pipeline.
Can we switch to demo, please?
So I'm going to peek
back and forth here.
So you can see here
that our change
was uploaded successfully.
And the multi-stage
Release Pipeline work, this
enables us to bring
together multiple projects
and multiple environments.
And the whole goal
here is to make it easy
for you to bring those pieces
together, to get your code out
to your users with
the push of your code,
or a click of a button.
So here we can see it
happened successfully.
But let's actually
go check to make sure
that the fix that we
committed worked as we expect.
So I'm going to go back and I'm
going to look at List Comments.
I'm going to click.
Click More.
It seems pretty fast.
Well, let's go look at
the Trace to be sure.
It's taking a second here.
It seems like it's got
updated. [LAUGHING] Demo-gods
in our favor, please.
TOMAS ISDAL: At least they're
on the opposite slide, right?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Oh, there we go.
TOMAS ISDAL: There we go.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
There we go. [LAUGHING]
So yeah, you can see
here that the change is
taking significantly less time.
So that makes me feel
better about pushing out
to production.
So now I'm going to go back
to the Release Pipelines
page in our Dev Console.
And I'm just going
to click Promote.
And that's it.
In the background,
we're going to start up
another Jenkins-based job
to build, test, and deploy
our app to production, so that
our users can see the change.
And the push will only happen,
if the build and tests,
if the results are all green.
So switch back to
the Preso, please.
TOMAS ISDAL: So
testing is important,
but it's only important
if you actually
run in production what
you tested earlier, which
is why we're so excited to
talk about the new Docker
Support for Managed VMs.
We had this full session
about Docker and containers
yesterday.
And if you Google search for
containerizing the Cloud,
it should be the
first hit, and you
can watch the recording of it.
So a Docker image is a bundle
that contains your application
binaries, but it also
contains all the dependencies
of your application.
This could be any static
files you depend on,
any operating system
libraries you depend on,
and maybe even the operating
system you depend on.
So all these files
are shipped around
as a bundle which
gives you confidence
that whatever you
run on your laptop
is the same as you run in PROD.
So from a demos
perspective, this
is great because it gives
us a testable bundle that's
portable between environments.
We can develop on our
laptop for quick iteration.
We can push it to staging.
We know it's exactly the same
bits as we test on our laptop.
We run a big suite of
test on it in staging.
And then when it's all green,
we can choose to push to PROD.
And again it's the entire
environment of your app.
So the Build, Test,
Deploy Pipeline
you saw here, it
is a Jenkins build.
It is compiling your
source, but the actual
build artifact its
producing is a Docker image.
So here we bundle in
your app, your libraries,
whatever other
dependencies you had
to get with a super
minimal Linux distribution,
by default, if that's
what you want to run.
And we put this into
Google Cloud Storage
so that it's accessible
from all the VMs,
reliably and quickly,
as the VMs boot up.
So putting all this
together makes Managed VMs
a really great way to package
and run your Docker containers.
So why containers then?
Well, at Google, we're super
excited about the increased
external popularity
of Docker containers.
So internally, we're
huge container users.
We have been using
containers since 2006.
And we contributed cgroups
back to the Linux kernel.
We're continuously contributing
our improvements, both upstream
into the Linux kernel, and
into Docker, Docker, Inc.
Today at Google
in production, we
start over 2 billion
containers per week,
and we're really excited to
take our experience with running
containers and contribute that
to the customers of Google
Cloud Platform.
So can we switch back
to the demo, please?
Well, we just pushed
fix to production.
Now let's go back and see if we
actually improved performance.
So in production, we could
do the same small test
as we just did in staging
by checking individual RPCs
and seeing how things are going.
However, what you
actually care about
is whether this change
improved performance or made
things worse for our users.
So with Cloud Tracing we
allow you to generate reports
where you slice and dice
your RPC data to figure out
whether latency
increased, decreased,
whether errors
went up and so on.
So since we just
pushed to production,
I'm going to use data from
earlier this week, since we
don't really have any real
production data just yet.
So this is data
from the same fix
that I did a couple days ago.
So we see here, as we
look at the Latency
Profile of these RPCs, we
see that the orange line is
the new version.
The median latency went
down to 43 milliseconds.
The resolution is
so low here, so I
have to scroll all the
way over to the right,
to see the tail latency
of the old implementation.
You see here, previously,
the old implementation
was running out in up to four
second request response time.
So not very good.
And as you debug
these tail latencies,
it's really useful to be able
to dig in deeper, to figure out,
I see this request
was really slow.
So we allow you to go and
look at representative traces
in a given latency percentile.
So I'm going to go
in here, and I'm
going to look at the
old implementation,
say the 90th percentile
latency, and see
what could go wrong here.
And again, we see
the step method
where the Datastore calls
just keep on getting repeated.
Here we fetched 8,150
comments before we
got the 50 comments
we were interested in.
So this gives you the ability
to really dig into your changes,
and make sure that whatever
you push to production
is actually improving
what your users see.
Can we switch back to slides?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Great.
So I'm going to talk a
little bit about testing.
So server-side and web ops
are just part of the story.
Most services have
mobile components, too.
And the mobile
landscape is diverse,
and it's changing all the time.
And for developers,
this presents us
with great opportunities, but
also significant challenges.
So for example, six
different Android OS versions
each have a market
share of over 10%.
And other popular
Android devices
cover an even bigger
span of screen sizes
and pixel densities.
So as a developer,
we have to make sure
that the apps we're building
will work on our users devices.
And releasing with confidence,
in this type of environment
that's changing so
quickly, it demands
testing across an extensive
matrix of devices,
API levels, and even languages.
So let's see how the
power and scale of Google
can make matrix
testing fast and easy.
Can you switch back
to demo, please?
So I'm developing a new
feature for the WalkShare app
we've been talking about.
And I'm doing that
in Android Studio.
And I wrote some tests using
the Espresso framework.
So I've tested my application
against a local emulator,
but now I want to
test it against some
of the most popular
configurations
for my customers.
And I start running the
tests in the usual way,
but in addition to local
devices and emulators,
I see I have this
new option here,
Run tests in Google Cloud.
And I'm going to select that.
And note in this
dialog box here,
you can see that
the tests are going
to run in my WalkShare
Google Cloud Project.
So let's go in here
So here, I can pick
the configurations
I want to test against.
And I have an existing set of
Matrix configurations already
defined.
You can see them here.
I have some Smoke Tests.
These are basic tests that
I run with every change.
I have some Release Tests.
These are more extensive tests
that I run with every release.
And then I have
some Sample tests.
Google will even use Play
Store statistics to come up
with a set of configurations
based on the statistics
that they have found.
So I also have an option here
of some configurations that
will cover most of
my user community.
And if I wanted to,
I can even select
all of the available test
configurations to run.
And it looks like
there's over 1,700 here.
But what I want to do is, I want
to dig in on the Smoke tests.
So I'm going to
pick my device here.
I'm going to pick Nexus 5, and
I'm going to pick the platform.
I'm going to pick API 18 and
19, or Jelly Bean and KitKat.
I'm going to pick the
locale, English and German,
and I'm going to pick the
orientation, which is portrait.
So I can see here
that my test will run.
These four configurations will
cover 20% of my current users.
So I also have this
option down here
to run tests on
physical devices.
And as you heard
yesterday, we're
very excited to welcome
Appurify to Google.
Appurify has a great
interface to enable developers
to test their apps
against physical devices.
And the interface is great.
It provides very
actionable feedback
so that you can fix things that
are wrong with your mobile app.
Appurify shares Google's
passion about making
great mobile applications
across both Android and iOS.
So I can't talk about
the specifics right now,
but I can say that
we do have plans
to offer Appurify's platform
as a cross-platform service
for all of our developers.
So now that I've picked
my configurations,
I'm just going to hit OK.
And I'm going to hit OK again.
And we can see here
that Android Studio's
building my application and
running all of my tests.
And it's going to upload them to
a Google Cloud Storage Bucket.
So it's not coming up quite
yet, but from there, Google's
going to run all of my
requested tests in parallel.
And as the tests
finish, the results
are going to stream back
to the Results Viewer,
so that I know exactly
what's going on.
And as the tests
complete, I can go dig in
and look at the details.
So you can see here
that those four test
configurations
are still running.
So we're going to
do a little Julia
Child since they take
a couple minutes.
And we're going to switch over
to the same configurations,
but the tests have
already completed.
And it's interesting.
Here I can see in the hierarchy,
the different API levels.
And I can see that I have
a test that's failed.
And it's on API Level
18 or Jelly Bean.
So from here, I can actually
go look at the code.
Oh, I can see, I
had a check in here
to test for whether or
not we're running KitKat,
and to throw an exception.
So this is an example of being
able to really dig in and find
issues that you need to fix.
Failure on particular APIs,
it's a pretty common problem.
But sometimes test
assertions, they
don't find all the issues
that we need to know about.
So with a couple of
additional lines of code,
my Espresso Tasks
will take screenshots.
Google will capture
those screenshots,
and stream them
back to me, so I can
look for issues that
may exist in the UI that
will affect my users
experience of the app.
So I'm going to pick on
this task that completed,
and I'm going to go take a look.
And I'm going to
do some comparisons
between my configuration.
So remember I picked English
and German, like this morning,
wanted to have US win.
So I'm going to scroll
through these now,
and you can see the
comparison here.
So this is the second
screenshot comparison.
I can see it looks like there's
a cut off of the translation
here, so that might be an issue.
That looks pretty good.
Looks pretty good.
Here's another issue.
This is not lining up correctly.
So I'd probably
want to fix that.
So neither one of
these issues would
have been triggered
by a test failure,
but it's pretty convenient,
pretty easy for me
to be able to check for
these types of issues
and be able to fix them so
that my users have the best
experience.
We think you should be able
to run Matrix Testing whenever
you want, not with Release.
And it should all
happen in parallel,
and it should be easy,
and you shouldn't
have to leave your IDE to do it.
So we covered a lot in
this testing section.
You saw how we were able
to run Android tests
across multiple devices,
OS versions, API
levels, languages,
all in parallel.
And you also saw how you
could look at the results.
You could drill in
to the actual code
to find out what
was going wrong.
So Matrix Testing
with Google Cloud
can help you develop and
release quickly and confidently.
And no matter which device
your users are using,
you'll be able to
fix the issues,
and push those releases
out to production.
So can we switch back to
the presentation, please?
So we've covered a lot of
content in this session.
So I just wanted
to quickly recap.
We started out with
Managed VMs, Google's way
of offering the benefit
of platform as a service,
with the full power
of Virtual Machines.
Then we showed our new ability
to capture Trace application
traffic and then use that to
identify performance issues.
But DevOps wouldn't be
complete without deployment.
We've built upon the
Push-to-Deploy concept
and are expanding it to include
Multi-stage Release Pipelines,
so you can know
which code is where,
and you can promote easily
between your environments.
And then finally, we showed
Cloud Testing, an easy way
to offer matrix testing for your
Build, Test, and Deploy Cycle.
So Google's working
hard to deliver
a full featured
DevOps stack for you.
And the part that I'm
most excited about
is that we're just
getting started.
So thanks so much
for coming today.
Thanks for coming to I/O. We'd
love to hear your feedback.
We have a sign-up page
there for Managed VMs.
And we also have
this offer, in terms
of getting started on
our Cloud Platform.
We're happy to take some
questions for a couple minutes,
if you'd like, and
thanks again for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Please
use the microphones
if you're going
to ask questions.
MALE SPEAKER: Other slide.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
It's the other slide.
Yeah, thanks Thanks.
[LAUGHING] You're in the back.
TOMAS ISDAL: Big room.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Give you time to walk.
Sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: Hello?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So the question
is-- great stuff--
so we've been seeing a lot
of stuff on Wearable and TV.
So is there anything
you can share in terms
of where there's
automation around testing
for that stuff in the
future, where that's going?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Not at this time.
I don't know.
We can try to hunt down
the answer for you,
but I can't tell you.
Thanks for asking.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Everything looks really cool.
So on the stuff with
Android testing,
is there just going to be
support for Espresso's testing
library to run with
matrix testing,
or are you going to support
Roboelectric or Vadim, all
these other testing
frameworks as well?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So yeah, we do
want to support other
testing frameworks.
Our philosophy is that we
want to meet engineers, meet
developers, where they are.
And so decisions around using
Jenkins, for example, the right
plug-ins to support the Build
and Test and Deploy Cycle,
that's just one example.
But I just used it
as an example today,
because that was what
we did for the demo,
but we do want to support other
types of testing frameworks.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Great stuff.
What actually did
the screen capturing?
Is that an API call
within the test,
or was that done by the CI job?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: I think that
was done by the actual test.
AUDIENCE: OK.
We actually use Espresso
over at Twitter,
and hopefully there is an
API for taking screenshots,
at least a stock API
that comes with Espresso.
So I was just
curious about that.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So yeah, we've
been doing it internally at
Google, and if you stay after,
I'll get you connected
with the folks
on the team that have done it.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: As far
as I know, you use
Jenkins to do with the testing
before deploying and stuff.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to get
access to the UI of Jenkins,
for example, to see
reporting and stuff?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah,
that's a good question.
You saw the wrapper
around it, because we
wanted to make it
as easy as possible
for you to interact with the UI.
Well, if you can stay after,
we could talk about it,
but part of what we were
trying to do with that
is just to make it
simpler and easy to use.
Have you spent a lot of
time using the Jenkins UI?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I've known Jenkins to do the
reporting stuff, so [LAUGHING].
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It would be great
to have it in just one place.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Just there.
Yeah.
We should talk about that after.
There are some challenges
with the Jenkins UI.
We have talked with the folks,
because again and such about,
there are some great
collaborations we can do there
around making
improvements to it.
That's a good question.
AUDIENCE: I will
come by afterwards.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah, thanks.
TOMAS ISDAL: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So most of the stuff
you demonstrated today
started with a build.
Do you guys have any plans
to integrate coder tools
like what internally
Google users, for example.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: [LAUGHING]
Where are you from?
AUDIENCE: I used
to work for Google.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
[LAUGHING] There you go.
AUDIENCE: Then the second
thing is like the dashboards,
like app.
I ran past, this test
started, actually
failing with this
comment essentially.
I want to know the history
of the [INAUDIBLE].
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So you have
the inside scoop. [LAUGHING]
AUDIENCE: But those
things naturally fit
as the next steps.
So do you guys have
any plans with that?
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Yeah, we've been
doing a lot of
thinking about that,
and we're really excited
about some of the things
that we're going to be working
on this year for our customers.
Great questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I used one of the first
versions a few months ago
that you released with
GitHub integration,
so it may even
builds automatically.
The question is, we use
three different builds.
We have the Continuous Build, we
have Integration Test, and then
the larger one.
How does that fit with
what we currently have?
You have those
integration pipelines.
Are they fixed somehow?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: So sorry.
The question is?
AUDIENCE: I want to
release to production
as soon as the integration
tests are completed,
but that takes about 20 minutes.
I want to release to some
kind of demo environment,
after I'd say, the continuous
fast tests run through.
So how are those Release
Pipelines configurable?
That's the main question.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Oh, good question.
So you want the
ability to set up
basically multiple pipelines?
AUDIENCE: It might be
related to the Jenkins UI,
to that question.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
Well, it sounds
like you want the flexibility
to be able to say,
I want this kind
of Release Pipeline
for this particular
type of application,
and you want to be able
to group those together.
So, yeah, we've
definitely been talking
about the ways in which
we can bring together
different projects and different
environments to make it easy.
You're just seeing
the first little steps
that we're taking to do that.
And we're excited to
do a whole lot more.
But yeah, we want it to
be as easy as possible
for you to configure and set
up different release pipelines
so that you can manage
them effectively.
And it sounds like
set up triggers
around certain conditions
as to when things will run?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Very interesting stuff, but
I think you're out of sync.
The Jenkins bug, in the demo,
you said you fix the bug,
you build, you test,
you deploy to staging.
And then when you showed
you deploy to production,
you say you build again?
You build, test,
and deploy again.
When you go to
production, you just
want to deploy, the same thing
as what we did in production.
So if we don't have
control on this.
Just wondering how much
we would be able to,
are you going to say,
you deploy like this?
You build and deploy like Google
decides, or can we choose?
TOMAS ISDAL: You wanted
a binary promotion,
so you want to make sure that
you want to promote the Docker
containers, not only the build
artifacts, but the world as it
looked when you ran the tests.
AUDIENCE: And when you
say as a Promote Return,
you're using the
Promote Plug-in.
And you have a build
job and deployment
jobs configured in Jenkins?
TOMAS ISDAL: Yes, so this
is just around the corner.
It wasn't in this demo, but
it's just around the corner.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Just
so I heard you correctly.
The key there is that you really
want the ability to configure
at each stage what
exactly happens.
AUDIENCE: At least
to know what happens.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah,
of course. [LAUGHING]
Yeah, forgive our demo
magic a little bit.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Somewhat related
to the last question.
How do you manage different
configuration settings
for your staging versus
production environments?
So you click Promote, but
you don't want necessarily
the same application
configuration
used as you go up the stack.
TOMAS ISDAL: So basically
different flags.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
TOMAS ISDAL: Well, they're
completely separate projects.
So you could imagine that you
have configuration stored in,
for example, the Datastore
that contains your flags, that
allows you to go in and edit
it before the next version.
So that's one way you can do it.
You might want to have
configuration files separately.
MELODY MECKFESSEL:
So we didn't show
any of the administration
behind this at all.
I don't know if the
Pipelines, if there's
going to be another
Pipelines talk,
but if you stay after, we
can get you some information.
We did a couple of
them at the Sandbox,
but it would be good
to probably give you
some more insight into
that, because we definitely
didn't cover that today.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering, I've
seen in all your demos
that they're Vadim based.
Do you support Gradle?
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yes,
we're working on that.
We're working on
Gradle integration.
We're looking at integration
with other build systems.
Yeah, I think the
idea is to support
what our customers, our
developers, are using.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MELODY MECKFESSEL: Thanks.
Thanks, everyone,
so much for coming.
It's late in the
day on Thursday.
We appreciate it.
Thanks for coming to I/O.